um Abba and preach these guys are idiots
now I did anyone actually watch this
admin preach [ __ ]
so you call this [ __ ] idiots for a
video you didn't even watch I Didn't
preach by the way I've never really
talked about them but they made a video
defending [ __ ] friction fresh and fit
yeah they have a lot of bad ticks yeah
it sucks I've watched a few of their
videos like earlier this year and I
thought they were hilarious me too but
then like yeah deeper dive it's like
[ __ ] I actually had the same opinion and
I was really surprised when they're like
yo fresh and fit there's no evidence to
accuse them you we didn't defend them we
defend the principle of it people says
you brought up somebody who came to tell
on some lies about somebody to disparage
their reputation and I hope one day when
you get caught in a much bigger Scandal
because it will happen all right
somebody will make up something about
you I hope that people don't just jump
on that bandwagon because they dislike
you how someone actually takes the time
to have the evidence and I hope one day
when you get caught in a much bigger
Scandal that day it has arrived
yeah yeah yeah
we have told you don't do it don't do it
you have gone and done it anyways you
are going to pay you have come to
understand that the very Behavior you
are engaging in it is a sickness
it is deviant therefore we do not want
it do not partake in this ever again
today's topic Ethan Klein's been banned
we got this clip from Ben Shapiro and
his response okay so if you don't know
what basically Ethan was saying like
you're saying if they round up uh you
know the Jewish folks again and there's
some some fumes that happen to be there
he hopes that Mr Shapiro goes first
essentially being like hey bro he was
being a gentleman there's another
Holocaust at least they start rounding
up the Jews again this went all over the
news obviously Ben Shapiro covered it a
bunch of other conservative news covered
it YouTube found out Crackdown and
basically banned his ass for a week on
YouTube the full contexts are having
discussion regards to how Ben Shapiro
and the people who work under him are
basically engaging in anti-jewish
sentiment namely Candace Owens is one of
the people and in the clip itself
basically he's talking about like you
know if bench up here wants to continue
supporting people like this
um then if the second coming of the
gassing of the juice happens I want Ben
Shapiro to go first I said to say you
are the one who helped contribute to
this situation so you should be the
first one to go now he said in a joking
tone let's be honest he's not a comedian
but he's trying to do comedy okay
I'm cool with the joke mostly because I
understand it's an attempt at humor he's
being very flagrant and very edgy for
the purpose of being like shock human
that's how Ethan tries to deal with his
jokes he sucks at them so that's the
full context now my take is people want
to tell jokes even if they're edgy I'm
fine with them me personally even if I
hate the person doing as far as this
band goes in the severity of it and the
whole media uproar I think it's unfair
because the fact that a lot of people
are moving the context in which he said
it and trying to make it sound like it
wasn't meant to be a joke which I think
is really important in this context
however I don't mind it so much because
Ethan is in the business of removing
context when he's attacking other people
even when he's confronted with the
entirety of the thing that he's raging
against he still refuses to contact the
price to ignore so Ethan is having
happened to him what he has done to many
other people wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
you said that one day
you said that one day in one video I
think you would talk about a video where
you was talking about fresh he was
talking to the fresh and fit girl and I
think you said something like
um Abba and preach these guys are idiots
now I didn't did anyone actually watch
this I've been preach [ __ ]
so you call this [ __ ] idiots for a
video you didn't even watch
and you didn't even
I didn't preach by the way I've never
really talked about them but they made a
video defending [ __ ] friction fresh
and fit yeah they have a lot of bad
ticks we didn't defend them we defend
the principle of it which is you brought
up somebody who came to tell on some
lies about somebody to despair is their
reputation and I hope one day when you
get caught in a much bigger Scandal
because it will happen all right
somebody will make up something about
you I hope that people don't just jump
on that bandwagon because they dislike
you how someone actually takes the time
to have the evidence so that's what
you're having happen to you right now
right this is the monster that you
created and now you're like everyone oh
my God it's a beast is a beast [ __ ]
that's your dog
you had the [ __ ] on the leash
all of a sudden it's out it's cage you
want to get mad at us because it's
devouring your face that's yours you
bred it you fed it and now it's eating
on you you coming out all dismembered
disfigured Oh no you're not
you the daddy
that's you
that's why you lose my sympathy and this
is why we warning people all this kind
of weird canceling culture stuff that
people are endorsing and pushing well
guess what when the tables are turned on
you you don't have much of a leg to
stand on in terms of sympathy you have
made a decision
to destroy the idea of context you have
left your abort you have said context
who is this we are going to kill it we
have warned you we said papaya don't do
it huh Ethan you have gone and done it
and now you are crying because of what
you have done before being done to you
and then you want sympathy from who
can you see me
from who not from me my friend I have
seen you lay down the bed now I'm
watching you sleep in it and you are
asking me to wake you up go to bed
you're going to sleep YouTube has gone
and they have given you a nice quill
you didn't even need the gas
no you just needed the drugs the
knowledge one day will enter your
cranium right okay
and then you want to come out and say
everyone is critiquing you as a
widespread that's not true now you're
alienating more people who may be
moderates who saw what you're saying as
flagrant right and you're labeling them
as like the second coming of the white
hoods
Ethan deserves everything that's
happening to him even if I don't wish on
him not because I don't think he's a
loser who deserves bad things to happen
to him not because of that because if
they do it means something worse for our
society as a whole the more stuff like
this happens the more it's gonna get
turned on me and preach your favorite
creators anybody in these spaces you
said that right the line keeps moving
all the time and more and more forms of
like de-platforming or canceling or
bands are happening and they're being
normalized I don't like that right so
that's why I'm against this not because
I like the dude [ __ ] him I don't care
what how you can jump out I don't care
what happens to the man but I don't like
the principle that's being upheld in her
society today that was probably what
your biggest call of the year what you
mean you called it Oh you mean the whole
election
you called it age
you said that you know it's a little
weird what when I said that I was
wearing those tops
he waited too
[Applause]
I give it another Holocaust happens
despite the fact that Ethan Klein seems
like a a rather unpleasant human being I
would hope that both he and his family
would Escape Ethan Klein
who is chuckling about the Holocaust
there he seems particularly fond of
Hamas in 2011 in 2021 he actually lied
about the state of Israel and Hamas and
basically soft petal Hamas is Terrorism
he said the Israeli government is making
me sick he's in the middle of the Gaza
War started by Hamas in which they were
firing literally hundreds of rockets
into the center of Israel even if Hamas
is operating out of a civilian building
it doesn't justify the total Destruction
of that building okay yeah listen you
know Ben Ben's got his strength got his
fault him being a prose really show is
one of his worst qualities I mean every
time this man encourages America and
North America and Canada to go to war on
behalf of Israel I [ __ ] cringe
incredibly but moving past that okay
because I don't want to get into
geopolitics on that stuff uh I
understand it's a joke as well I get
that I I get that but I also understand
why he got banned
um I'm not happy with it am I whatever
it's whatever to me but
there are certain things if there's
certain jokes that you want to make make
them
you can make them definitely there's
going to be on certain platforms some
consequences especially like that
especially it's it's uh man it's just
how the joke is gonna it's constructed
you want someone how do you think
someone that is super Jewish as gen as
as Shapiro
it's gonna take the [ __ ] joke and if
he takes the joke bad and reports it of
course other people are going to report
it and then hence you're going to get
banned eventually I don't want him to
get banned I don't care
but I'm like what did you expect it's
really what did you expect am I wrong
for thinking what did you expect
like I think if you tell me he got
banned I heard what he said and I'm like
joke or not I'm like duh yeah
there's a lot of people that get banned
for less than that doing a joke on that
even though it's a joke I understand
that the reality in which we'll live in
if you do certain things something's
gonna happen
I don't agree with them but yeah the
truth is on YouTube not all comedy can
exist there okay I've been some dark
comedy shows where there's jokes about
dying babies or jokes about well there's
some wild jokes and dark comedy spots
that YouTube just can't exist why
because advertisers YouTube is on that
PC train I don't think it's good I don't
like it um anyway I woke up early this
morning and I went over to leftovers and
I shot leftovers and you guys won't be
able to see the episode if you weren't
watching live and the reason for that is
because it's been taken down they came
after our boy they came after Ethan for
saying things uh that were definitely
you know a little a little spicy a spicy
facility okay he went real full spice
okay he went spicy facility with it and
uh and of course he caught a strike
because conservatives love outrage well
I watched it live OMG yeah I'm not gonna
talk about it listen he just said some
[ __ ] about Ben Shapiro that
conservatives are complaining about and
crying about because he said Ben Shapiro
who will be responsible for the next
Holocaust uh he just said he hopes he
goes first in it okay and of course that
understandably was weaponized by
conservatives of course it was going to
what be weaponized by conservatives I
don't know what he was thinking
obviously you know what I mean Ethan was
suspended by the way a few white
supremacists successfully lobbied
YouTube to suspend me a Jewish Jewel
citizens of Israel USA for anti-Semitism
major on friends convergencing all they
want but ultimately they are the ones
platforming dangerous anti-semites all I
did was point it out is it a Perma or
temp I think it's it's probably going to
be a Perma yeah and it wasn't the
leftovers episode that got him suspended
it was the prior one no I didn't say
Perma someone else in the chat said
Perma I'm not saying it's Perma one week
one week one week uw7 is Perma but
whatever maybe it's just a misspeak
um that's a good point also
conservatives always talk about being
put for free speech do a lot of pearl
clutching when they hear jokes that they
don't like
and that was a joke you may not like the
joke you may not think it's the greatest
joke but conservatives are always crying
about free speech and stuff like that
you find out that a lot of them once the
joke is directed at them or something
that they care about me the most
whatever it might be then all of a
sudden they do the pro clutching too and
when we start to realize that even
though the left is engaged in most of
the cancer that I've seen conservatives
do a pretty good job when they want to
themselves
they do this shouldn't have been a big
news story other than the fact that it's
Ethan Klein who said it and he's the
person who's in the business of
canceling others outside of that who
cares he made an edgy joke get over it
people should be able to say these jokes
that's the truth but
the climate today I know this is not the
case and I'm not a fan of it maybe you
guys feel differently so y'all can let
us know below but I just don't like the
climate today man there's money involved
you know what I mean yeah the meaning
there's money involved people are going
to be able to well the argue make
ostrich out of it yeah if it was just a
YouTuber that was not making any money
nobody would have cared yeah you know
what else I hate what you've been
happening a lot it's like everybody
frames the opposition to their stances
as the worst people possible oh you're
critiquing me you're doing it for the
views you're an unethical person oh
these people want me off the platform
they must be white supremacists oh these
people hate me they must be race oh
these are blacks Oh my days not
everybody who's against something you've
done is coming from an extreme position
why is it always spring that way it's
such a decision it's such a disingenuous
way to engage with some of this stuff
right and it removes any ability for
accountability because you essentially
pay the other person as being some
disingenuous actor right
and then you don't look at yourself to
see like maybe the medium in which I did
this wasn't the right place or you know
maybe since I'm more of a serious person
generally I shouldn't be making these
kinds of comments or maybe like the
context in which I'm saying this isn't
the right place you can find mediums for
both
right a comedian going to a random spot
and doing the crazy drug that outrages
somebody maybe that individual crash
shouldn't be there but the comedians are
also taking accountability recognize
what kind of comedy show he's in because
plenty of comedy clubs do not want
extreme forms of jokes
both sides can take accountability these
kinds of things but if you frame the
other person as crazy or your friend the
other person as someone who hates your
very existence and wants you disappear
you can't engage with that because who
would engage with a monster but the
truth is the person across from you
isn't always a monster they're just
someone who would diametrically opposed
views so I just I hate the way people
frame everything it's just like I hate
her or they're a hater or sometimes they
just don't like that one thing you said
they don't like that one thing you said
you're a hater no no that one thing you
said I can't go against that no I'm a
hater automatically people use those
terms too much yeah I mean sometimes
it's just one thing
it's not a majority of things I can hate
I can hate 30 of what you say I still
like 70 calm down yeah but you a hate
calm down I'm like 70. 70 is not enough
I know I got to like everything
it's not a fan so I don't agree with
that [ __ ] you were a hater yeah come on
now but you gotta hold this out man
hey yo chat not mad if you guys are
watching right now we're supposed to do
a whole video on Ethan Klein and uh you
know the whole roast thing if you guys
want to see that leave some comments and
some likes below if we get to around 50K
I promise you I put out a video I got
some stuff that I've been researching on
Mr L3 L3 so we should consider doing
that
you know they're gonna click all right
man listen 50k likes if we get it there
you know I'm saying I got you guys 50
clicks 50k 50k yeah
I think we'll do it